After drawing conclusions and
thinking predictions,
the final step of the process
is to communicate your findings.
Now, even though you don't have rigorous
conclusions backed by statistics or
machine learning, you can certainly
think about how to communicate
the results of your exploration.
At this stage,
you generally want to decide which
of your findings you think are most
interesting or most worth sharing, and
how you want to present those findings.
For example, I was interested in
the difference in total minutes spent in
the classroom between students
who passed the first project and
students who didn't.
And I think the clearest way to present
this is simply to present the means for
both groups.
I also thought the difference in number
of days visited in the first week
was interesting.
And then this case,
I thought the histograms did a better
job of showing back numbers.
If you do want to share
any visualizations,
in general it's a good idea to
spend some time polishing them.
You want to make them look nicer and
explain what trends
you'll noticing in them.
You always know what you made a plot of,
but your reader doesn't.